to the girl on Facebook who commented
hashtag all lives matter
after deeming the protest she attended a
hateful event Martin Luther King would
have been ashamed of call it an
overreaction call it a riot a violent
protest call it everything but justified
asked us to be polite to stay calm to
voice grief with respect while our
brother's bodies are laid out on the
street sounding the alarm our bodies our
threats well before they are human and
you still want to know the source of our
rage you fear our rage will happen
across a storefront window will happen
across the corporate office you fear the
glass shards glittering under police
helicopters we fear your rage will drag
our children into the streets and dance
in the red pool beaming under street
lamps I cannot decorate this pain for
you I cannot make a beautiful omage I
can't invoke hope in prayer I don't know
how to make you understand the
occupation your ignorance has blinded
you to that black bodies are stopped and
frisked so often we might as well call
our cities war zones every street corner
a checkpoint violence is not always a
dead body violence can be a pat-down in
broad daylight because you share the
same hue as suspect violence as in
dining the man who filmed the killing of
Eric garner but not the officer that
illegally choked the life out of his
body while five others assisted in the
arrest of violence is convincing a jury
that he caused his own death that had he
not been overweight he would have
survived violence is needing six
officers to arrest one unarmed
non-violent man in the first place how
can we accept a government that only
applies the law to fill prisons with
lack bodies how can we accept a
government that permits and perpetuates
violence against its people the state
traded white hoods for police uniforms
the cops kill more black people each
year than the KKK lynched and you want
our marches peaceful you want us calm
you want us quiet stop asking us to bite
our tongues when we cannot guarantee our
siblings safe passage to the corner
store yet you still want to talk about
looting want to police our protest
tactics you want me to know that you
would have cared about the tombstones
this nation is hoarding if we hadn't
blocked traffic you think stopping
trains is silly you want us to march
peacefully to replicate your disfigured
perception of Martin but dr. King said
riots are the voices of the unheard and
you will hear us now it is not enough
for you to hold our dead in your prayers
to wish us love and light I get the
sentiment but it won't keep my kin from
becoming ghosts I am NOT interested in
resignations or remorse
I don't want apologies I don't want your
guilt
I don't want your tears I don't want
insistence on how not racist you are I
don't want to know how many black
friends you have when you won't even
risk the discomfort of calling out your
own classmates you just don't get it do
you you've never lived out the aftermath
the empty seat at the dinner table the
now widowed mother with six mouths to
feed my kin are being sent to heaven
well before God has requested their
return and you want to know why Malcolm
called whiteness the devil you can say
all lives matter but all lives are not
killed every 28 hours all lives will
matter when black lives matter how many
more bodies will be enough
how many videos of our last words how
many more must there be for you to
finally call this a genocide
you